[Music]
20 international chess professionals
converge here in st. Louis for the 2017
winter chess classic hello chess fans
it's Monday March thirteenth 2017 time
for the winter chess classic round
number three in Group A there are four
players in the lead at one and a half a
piece in Group B Christian carrilla has
a clear lead at two points going into
the round but there's still seven more
left so we'll see what happens these
players will earn top level tournament
experience but also there's a
twenty-thousand-dollar prize fund at
stake the winner of group a nets $5,000
the winner of groupie that's four
thousand dollars Group A has Darius
spirit I'm doing my best with your name
how do you say your name [ __ ] spirit
consider like in the heavens i was
saying boy I was telling him earlier i
can't i'm having some trouble with half
of the name of this field but we're all
doing our best here but we got to try to
get it right so Darius today you had
black against Grandmaster Cordova and
you were victorious congratulations on
that victory and I would like to have
you take us through the game multiplay
95 and this move sprightly so I thought
that now okay I first of all I mean I
was kind of shocked because I didn't
excite hoto is but then I realized that
I when he moved his night from from a
free he's put on his King and kanonji to
it kind of maybe under attack so I
decided picking gauge which appears I
mean I think it's very strong because
for example if he plays on Queen 85 I
just take he can take with pawn because
Queen takes d5 and if he takes with the
rock I entered go to BG ADA has very big
problems with one on g2 so because of
this stupid square and shop 25 so and
yeah he played will be free and Queenie
593
trying to hold the night only five and
maybe to put negative for any way
position is already very difficult for
fried I suppose 93 root g 8 i'm going at
four Bishop h6 and if you'd have stayed
taken on the five I would take with
Queen obviously and now probably has to
play you will get three but this is
looking very bad just a cig night d
frequently before for example we just
collect the palms so it's like very very
bad for white but he's a 93 and now I
started to think what should i do
because i normally i would like to play
for example be sure before increasing
the pressure after Queen 85 it appears
that white is doing very well because
the Friday job takes before and my queen
unified is hanging so I decided to play
very simply very simple just a quickie
seven and interning just after 95 to the
capture and be just one up I mean no
enough composition for sure for white I
think was the best option would be five
e-cigs also kindly remove Roxy one and
now I play the things from google show
before the intended just to exchange
this bishop for the night and having in
mind that too broken if I was kind of
trapped so I will be action the prism
saying that my opponent decided to give
the exchange a measly and maybe try to
set some traps for my king order and 95
and now it was tricky moment a bit that
I mean I must take only five probably
because if I just try to say do whatever
I mean brigade yet for example I would
have been loved by 96 mate into so I
need to take this night if it takes pawn
rook a beautiful Swiss bank nice move
because i want to touch improve the last
pieces this is the cousin is not trying
yet look before here already when here
like one minute I have like five minutes
so we started playing a quicker a queen
7 rook takes 40 before and this was this
was nice that he cannot take on before
because I take Queen a7 look fa and he
is not gone so its undefeated this guy I
just go Quincy five trading quaint and
over there so after beautiful days
before I played before and this should
be completely full from black because
such as Isaac changeup and 24 not into
the rest was kind of I think it may be
one moment was interesting here yet that
I mean Roxy Iran's amo when I mean he if
he takes only seven then I just go Quinn
takes d5 and Queen f7 and if we for
example I mean almost anything should
complete Ewing if I'd for the squinty
eight and now if you run for a tag like
when 895 this was interesting the Queen
deep regístrate Queens ain't over so if
Queen a 7.7 and now also I wasn't sure
because it was very nice move I want to
make sure that I play kind of fight with
a free water who might have been a
little bit careless because of 9h 5c to
Queen g5 for example and here's some
like huge threat and maybe I mean during
the game I didn't see how can I probably
at five your body's completely
unnecessary for me so 25 it was very
good and 20 pages also nice maybe you'll
gain is also possible or a thousand will
use more precise okay also on it's good
so Queen you on rocked a day to its 586
I mean this Ricardo such as anything
flow right here at frequency for kind of
nice move and yeah he returned here
because my bones are smooth on and oh I
want to play me 22 an account in perfect
Queen like let's say Quimby one because
of made here so here he resigned
a great victory over the Peruvian
Cordova now you're a part of a very
exciting program the inaugural year of
alejandro ramirez as the coaches the
slough chess team how how has that been
so far mmm it's very good i like being
living in a display so insolently i
think the program is for me personally
great opportunity to improve my husband
too I mean often refuse academical me
why so I am glad to be in a lewis and we
are also very happy other team to
qualify to Final Four in like into
obstacles in our inaugural year so it's
we are very happy to qualify immediately
with with our team and we will try to
show our bus in New York in the end of
the month well that's awesome stuffing
if you don't know Darius yet this guy
remember one the third and supposedly
final sorry Maurice millionaire chest
open polio yeah it looks like it's going
to be the final unfortunately but hey
the millionaire champion forever I guess
huh well with two out of three points so
far another one of the names to watch in
Group A Darius congratulations thank you
very much I to me let's take a look
after three rounds at group A's standing
with six rounds left to go in Group A we
finally have a clear leader English
Grandmaster David Howell sits at two and
a half points in this section on Tuesday
March 14th the game to watch will be
between Darius spirits and Vladimir
Theodosius both players are sitting at
two points apiece all right I'm here in
the third round with Grandmaster and
rave Irish poets who had the white
pieces against Francesco Rambaldi of
Italy and take us through Andre this
game and show us what happened sure I
felt like I'm completely winner Bishop
of six night the fourth was pretty poor
and here it's misha page for you should
be sellin and you I thought like the
only line for black a skinny shade with
an idea if I take on the six then like
have something like taking a frankly I
office of the disc completely waiting
for me so we can each 17 just simply 97
and what is winning so in just seven is
pretty much the only move when here
blacks idea that if I play a 97 which
seems like the most natural then let
them take on f1 in each two and you reek
of cigs very important resource for
black because just don't the only way to
stop Quinn from penetrating the TG 6 and
you made energy it is the best move and
then like just simply can try to hold
this position so this one actually looks
like kind of a fortress maybe even take
annunciators also deserves attention and
just play this position of course like
it should be winning for a wide however
for example for Bishop g5 it becomes not
that clear so whether i'm winning or not
so I don't know my D Queen B seven and
then yeah but so this is not that clear
but I thought like I'm just winning here
not not by taking on the seven but i
have rook afraid this one is an
important line and yeah here just simply
windy for something like that I thought
that I have Lucas one kind of a strong
move on simply my neck next move with 95
and there is no defense against Queen g6
so this just looks completely waiting
for a wide so yeah I guess like my
opponent from like found the best way to
defend to defend this position so he
played in g7 and the frankly I didn't
expect Queen g5 at all so we get cleared
it it was the best moment position
because it takes only 6 i'm just sitting
given maiden in many regions for example
this one is nice if we need seven the
age of six i can click on afraid take
take and write something like this
if for example he takes on a four then i
also have a simple idea just be should
be three jacks g8 ruka for and this one
just looks completely winning for the
white you should be five fruit g4 or
even Queen just 60 yet just hopeless for
black so yeah but but you found like
pretty much the only idea and now it
turned out that my position is not
winning by itself so I really expected
that I'm gonna win in one or two moves
but then I just turned out that this one
became really tricky so I took only
eight especially like at this point we
both had little time so it's pretty much
only moves for for both sides yeah night
h3 was possible but here I believe like
like us maybe when fine in this position
example rookie one and after trading
drugs for example or maybe it's not it's
not that precise but not a gimmick maybe
this is still with some chances for
black I don't know or also black and
take on before I believe so yeah that
was kind of an option for me however I
thought like you want is more natural
however is more may be risky I don't
know because rukia one looks pretty
normal and here i just woke hated that i
found this idea was queen of five
because otherwise it's not clear how I'm
gonna just get rid of all those pins and
what what I'm going to do with this
bishop so Queen a flat was ok and here
for example 94 also nice idea a cup 96
that is also important and here aqui
nishat is the only move for black
otherwise I just might like me into and
here's our simply Queen six of seven
yeah now I see that it's even easier for
a wide because I felt like I pretty much
have to take on the phone with the king
and also took swimming or now I see that
may be queen of one was a even just
easier win because now just like an
ithaca nation because of Queen f7 yeah
so that's why his decision to take on
this one was pretty much the only one
yeah and here it became also not clear
so maybe can afraid was an option i
wasn't sure if i if I'm win those kind
of signs you might begin afraid
something like this hmm so I can of
course i can give a lot of checks get
some time but here i wasn't sure if i
can win this one so it should be winning
as closest but became a little too here
over here i think like cry 7i g3 yes
another important failure i guess i'm
just reading into play night at five
yeah and ride on King good ideas from
black you look soo in but but once again
I in the game I wasn't sure that this
line is winning so I was just happy that
if you keep play skinny freighter then I
can just give a lot of checks and then
see what's going to be so just get some
time but after kenichi yeah it was also
at first glance not that clear so he
played Quincy five which I'm not sure it
wasn't a good idea so I calculate the
king of Qin h 1 unit 224 and here it's
important to take up kunis chemistry
that's day and here like like is almost
ran out of checks so its nightly to them
simply ki need to and then this look is
just hope hopeless for black however
here maybe Quincy five and it's it looks
pretty much the same as happenin begin
also I have a feeling that this should
be winning for white and maybe just not
that difficult however like impractical
being one you have little time at six
never
you know to understand this is
completely winning and there are no
threats like many major about here up
tonight for you just also looks
hopefully because of the idea of 96 yeah
so I don't see any music Knight d2
denied oh yeah so then don't assume that
this is just simply hopeless for black
and Hughes on Quincy five so black side
edges to play Quincy one and Queenie
Theresa for example you should be three
was attractive how about it just pretty
much gone them over I can lose like that
so let's be like I have to be precise to
live again so keeping jawan very simple
idea so and now like like I just done
with all those checking you just simply
simply winning for whitey for example 93
then I have I guess different options
maybe night afore is also the best one
so I'm protect energy to and threatening
to play majestic yeah and of course like
all day and games for example
hypothetically like manages to trade
Queens somehow but i am not sure how to
do this one so if Quincy five I also
have my teach five which is an important
also your flex a DMV if Queen takes you
five didn't take you for HTG 5m yeah
we're just regaining the kids about his
night night each five or even g4 I mean
like too many good moves for why yeah
but what's happening in the game it was
even neither softer Queen streak in each
to Quincy five and here is I said Lee
Colson with many options but it says
bishop as fascist the most precise and
here like just simply making food for
why
well congratulations Andre on the
victory now you are a student in tech at
Texas Tech what's it been like working
with that Chef powerhouse oh well it's
all I don't know it's it's just later so
yeah we have a great team so or a
supportive guys also our coach I think
it is the best coach I'm on like all
University coaches wagon for me
personally yeah and I don't just just
fun and I asked you like a progression
so even though its own maybe maybe not
that obvious because like you may want
to how can you progress on your study
almost all your fireman however like
this atmosphere is like in spirit I feel
like it's really cold there's something
we said about a really good fit when you
find one and it sounds like you do have
one now unfortunately there's no rest
days at this tournament so first time in
st. Louis I don't imagine you're getting
too much time to sightsee but what is
your experience been like so far in the
gateway city all right but I wasn't from
Lewis one year ago so oh yeah i was
attending yes championship and i spent
here one weekend in the year also what I
managed to do last year I wish the zoo
and also with the Botanical Garden of
course I was really excited to see like
such a beautiful place but he here
you're right in this room honest I
basically have no free time for a fight
scene and weather is not nothing good
just used to be like even in April last
year yeah we actually had really good
weather the past few weeks and then we
have the winter chess classic coming up
and it's really kind of funny because I
said well it's more like spring or
summer time now and then winter was like
we'll be back just in time for the
tournament don't you worry so yeah the
weather is pretty crappy right now right
so yeah I was wondering why the
tournament this cold winter classic but
then like yeah looking at the weather
and I understand it looks just right
right right well with two and a half
point so far in Group B you're
definitely one of the faces to watch so
congratulations on your game today Andre
and let's take a look at
Group B after three rounds have been
played with six rounds left to play ruby
has two leaders with two and a half
points of peace Ukrainian Grandmaster
Andre bearish poets and Romanian
Grandmaster eewan Christian kerala the
game to watch on Tuesday March 14th in
Group B will be bars poets vs. celebrity
Grandmaster been fine gold the 2017
winter chess classic runs every day
through sunday March 19 rounds begin at
one p.m. each day except for the final
round see the games live as they happen
on us chest champs calm and chest 24.com